hello my name is reto Meier I'm Ian new
Lewis we'll be looking at home screen
widgets and interviewing Kevin berry of
Tesla coil software to learn some tips
and tricks for improving in the
efficiency of your widgets all the next
30 minutes on this week's applicant is
our an interesting category is they can
be either released by themselves or
value adds to existing apps by providing
a window into your app directly on the
home screen we're just gonna be a
powerful tool for increasing user
engagement and encouraging people to get
back to your app now to get started you
really need to think about how you're
going to present your widget so perhaps
more than any other app type which is
really need a lot of attention to detail
on the design side even before you start
developing that's right because they're
always there and they're very very small
absolutely so start by checking out the
widget design patterns on the design tab
at developer.android.com and then it's
time to head over to the app widgets API
guide where you can learn all the
practical details of exactly how you put
your design and action so we're not
going to go into the specific details of
how to build an app as all of that
information is already available online
but we do want to do is have a look at
some tips for making your widgets a
little bit more awesome right users love
widgets as a way to keep information
front and center and as a way to
customize your home screen so that's
designed uniquely for you now with
limited space available on the home
screen it's important to do a good job
to keep your widgets and help them stay
front and center right you don't want
people getting annoyed with your widgets
and uninstalling them exactly so it
comes down to doing things like this not
draining the battery making sure that
they have timely up-to-date information
that they have a UI that's consistent
with the platform but it's still
representative of what your app is
trying to do and then there should be as
interactive as they can be yeah
absolutely it's really annoying to have
a widget that's just sitting there being
a larger version of a shortcut if you
want to be able to not only put
information on the screen but also make
it accessible so for instance the
calendar widget does a great job of that
and so over the years the power of
widgets has increased as the platform
has developed to give greater support
for how they can be integrated with
their
now this started with support for
collection widgets including lists and
galleries and then we added the ability
to resize widgets which told me God says
my calendar more recently also provided
support to embed widgets directly into
the lockscreen
and this is open up a whole new world of
possibilities absolutely yeah
this is extremely powerful it allows you
to users to perform actions or view data
without even having to unlock their
phone now as is typically the case along
with this great power comes
similarly great responsibility so it's
really important to take a few
proportions when allowing your widget to
be locked screened enabled the first
thing you want to think about is being
careful about exposing information so
the thing is your lock screen is what
you see when the phone's not lock or
when the phone is long so anyone can you
know pick up the phone and see that
information if you're exposing things on
that lock screen that have to do with
you know meetings you're having at work
that have confidential topics you know
people that are phoning you whatever you
have to remember all of that information
is going out into the world absolutely
in many cases that's a decision for the
users to make particularly with
something like calendar or email it's up
to you how sensitive you think that is
but you need to make sure as a developer
that it's really obvious to your users
what data or actions that they're
effectively removing that lock screen
protection from now for most user data
that's fairly obvious but especially for
actions it's important to protect any
actions that might cost the user money
or risk exposing private information you
may want to make sure that's an act in
an activity that's launched from the
widget not directly available on the
widget itself and you know even though
it's a it should be obvious to the user
what they're exposing when they add a
calendar or text message or recent calls
a widget to their home screen you might
want to give them a little reminder
anyway because a lot of times you think
oh yeah I'm gonna put my calendar there
and you don't dig deep and think wow
sometimes my calendar has some pretty
sketchy stuff on it absolutely so today
we're going to look at three home screen
widgets starting with the minimalist
shortcut and care
clock widgets and then we'll break out
the scalpels for a particularly
penetrating look at - clock from our
very own Roman Nurik who turns out isn't
a very good designer at all in his app
isn't with garbage I'm just kidding
let's take a look at minimalist shortcut
okay so I love that this widget
maintains its philosophy within its logo
and banner so it's all about minimalism
and they've they've taken that approach
here I probably go a step further though
and consider removing the declutter your
home screen text and really tighten up
that banner a little bit more I think
nothing really adds a lot of information
and actually just makes it a little bit
less minimalist so you know I actually
have the opposite feel idea I think it's
kind of cool actually okay there you go
um now this is a screenshot provided in
their Google Play listing and it's worth
noting that it's not immediately obvious
where the widget actually is but that's
as much a feature as it is a bug in this
particular instance as the point of this
app is to try and have these very
minimalistic widgets now one of the
confusing things is that each of the
screenshots has a different wallpaper
and a slightly different layout so it's
difficult to tell what's a widget and
what's a background and when things are
changing and how so in any case you can
see what they're trying to achieve here
with each of those tiny little androids
really light gray on the dark gray
background along the edge of the screen
now I want to start by calling out a
common challenge for widget developers
and if you're building the app that
happens to have a widget then there's a
variety of things that you can do to
help encourage your users to check out
the widget and even if they never find
it they can still use the app but what
if as in this case it's just a widget
well a lot of developers will still
choose to include a launcher activity to
help users find and activate that widget
and there's nothing wrong with that
that's that's perfectly appropriate it
stops people from hitting install and
then going I installed your app and I
can't find it but as this is going to be
the users first interaction with your
app it's really important to make sure
that the aesthetic of your app is
maintained in this introductory activity
so in the case of minimalist widget that
means paying a little more attention to
the padding and maybe even considering
switching to something like a light
style with a white background something
which matches the banner the
this idea of minimalism it's also worth
noting that the specific instructions
like the ones given here they're going
to change depending on the OS version
and in fact on my jelly bean device this
doesn't work long pressing on the on the
home screen doesn't bring up the widget
chooser so something you want to think
about when providing specific
instructions that you may want to check
to see what version of the OS it is and
even still a lot of users are going to
have their own custom launches their own
custom home screens which are going to
be different again so you really want to
consider perhaps providing links to
external resources rather than telling
people exactly what they should do now
it's worth mentioning that when you're
talking about the padding this is one
thing that makes your app look really
unprofessional is when they you've just
got a big block of text and goes all the
way across because obviously you didn't
really do any layout but as I learned
while we were trying to do some sample
apps last week it's actually really
really difficult to make that look
attractive so we're gonna put out a
sample app fairly soon here about making
good readable text layouts that work
from Froyo on up you can do it with
spaces on jelly bean but
jelly bean you know I think actually is
not yes but pre-ics you didn't have it
so the purpose of minimalist shortcut as
I've kind of implied already is to let
you have shortcuts to your favorite apps
while keeping your screen as simple as
possible it's basically a way of having
shortcuts without covering up your
awesome wallpaper I know they're
currently in beta so if this sounds like
something you're into now would be a
great time to download the app provide
them some feedback help and build
something even more awesome now speaking
of which here's a little bit of candid
feedback for you guys to help you create
an even better app this is the config
activity that's displayed when you add a
new widget it's got everything you need
but the presentation could be a little
challenging shall we say now this is
something that comes up a lot on the app
clinic and I know a lot of developers
you know find this to be kind of really
nitpicky advice so I'm going to explain
just really quickly why this is so
important why we keep harping on about
this most users are going to judge both
the utility and quality of an app within
the first few seconds of opening it up
now fairly or not most of that judgment
is instinctual and it's based on the UI
aesthetics and the usability of that up
so that first impression here is if
something really quite complex there's
this list of options that's totally
comprehensive but that also means it's
really long so I'm scrolling for a long
time before I see everything that's
there now as a first time user I'm not
sure which of these settings is required
which are optional and in fact the most
important setting the one which lets me
choose the shortcuts and the icons that
I want to use isn't obvious to find and
in fact it's not even here on the front
page now getting this right is a
challenge and in fact it's probably the
area for a lot of widgets where you're
going to need to spend the most time in
terms of your design is figuring out how
do you present this one-off config
settings to people in a way that they
can find intuitive and not you know not
challenging you want to have the things
you need there without hiding too much
of the functionality but you don't want
to display everything and intimidate
them until they go away so in a lot of
cases this is where good defaults and
easy editing comes in really handy you
just need to make it really easy for me
to create that first widget and then
with some really sensible defaults so in
this example you may choose some of the
most common you know pre packaged apps
build shortcuts to them directly with
what you think of the most common icons
and then make it really easy for users
to click something within your widget
set to to edit that and modify it all
right so that's that's all I want to
talk about in terms of in terms of
minimalist shortcuts pretty good app I
think it's basically some submit picker
UI changes you can make it even more
powerful so let's take a look at Tara
time by a top developer sterling doodle
now I love the icon a little less
excited about the banner she's a little
crowded wouldn't you agree yeah this is
one of those banners where it feels like
there there was a lot of effort put into
a certain set of elements on the banner
and then the rest of it was like handed
off to an intern or something Tara tine
there is it's in a really flat font it's
it's not probably the best font for this
it would be very difficult to read on a
small device but the background bitmap I
love it
absolutely and it gives you a really
good indication of yap now I should
point out having looked at Terra time
and this is this is not a new app you
can see that sterling is in fact one of
our top developers so this is a really
popular app that a lot of people love
and once we get to see some of the
screenshots you'll see just how
beautiful it is and so making sure that
that first impression is consistent with
the awesome graphics of the app itself I
think is you know a really simple but
important first step that you can take
interesting now unlike minimal shortcuts
Terra time is an app as well as a widget
so it has the advantage of being able to
show this when you launch the app and
now this is a pretty stunning UI you've
got the earth semi lit based on the
current time you've even got the the
lights in the in the night sky you know
showing on the area that that is
currently at night which is incredible
but we're not looking at apps today so
let's take a look at the widgets that
you can install so there are in fact two
of them and this is what they look like
and they're both visually stunning
they're really good examples of the
power of a widget to really customize
your homescreen and make it something
that you really like to look at and I
think it's fair to say that both of
these options are significant
improvements over the default analog
clock widget I think yeah so Sterling's
biggest challenge here is really around
efficiency he's got this rich dynamic
content that needs to be regularly
updated and when you're building widgets
it's vital that you minimize the
required update frequency of them and
also minimize the amount of data that
you're regularly sending to your widget
so you'll note for example that there's
no second hand on the display so at most
he's only going to need be a need to
update that widget every minute and
hopefully he's found ways to do it even
less frequently than that it's also
great to see that both widgets are
resizable and they're available as lock
spring widgets as well and in fact after
playing with this today I've set the
globe widget as my new default home
screen icon lock screen icon because it
just looks so stunning and they've done
a really great job in that it scales
really well between when it's sort of
full lock screen between when the
keyboard is available and
and that the globe is compressed so
really thrilled really impressive and
now we're going to learn some of the
tricks that you can use to have
something like this as rich UI without
draining the battery or you know risking
crashing the launcher when we talk to a
Kevin later today so well let's finally
let's take a look at dash clock and you
release from our very own room and Urich
I think you looked at this a normal date
yes yes and let's just get it out of the
way right now this is a masterpiece of
beautiful clean intuitive designs that's
the standard by which all maps armymen
measured and i it's the last lockscreen
widget you will ever need so let's rip
it apart a little bit so first off the
the lockscreen or I'm sorry the Nami had
a feature or graphic I think could be a
little bit better done and they the the
title has more space that it could take
up I don't think you should be afraid of
letting your title overlap other
elements in your scene it needs to be
really really big and especially with
extremely minimalist feature graphic it
could really use a little bit more in
fact I would take out the device with a
3d look and maybe just zoom in on the
widget itself to help people understand
what it is but really it just bidded
because there's all those gradients in
the background I know he never lets meet
ingredients I think he has the gradient
license well it makes me feel a little
bit better that he still feels forced to
use that that horrid blue that he makes
us use
okay so this is a wonderful app that
this is what you see when the app is
launched there's a very obvious set of
extensions it's really really easy to
understand how you're gonna add an
extension because he went ahead and put
an ad extension button as the last thing
in this list it's really easy to manage
the extensions in fact the only
complaint I had was that probably
because I'm old I wasn't able to
rearrange the extensions very easily you
know once you get a lot of extensions in
here Roman did put in a great
drag-and-drop rearranger it's very very
fast it's very very fluid but it only
works if you grab the absolute left hand
side there where that little bit map
handle is the one that says grab me
obviously but the reason I I feel like
this is a worth talking about is that
you can swipe the notification or swipe
the extension to dismiss it just like a
notification and you can swipe it from
anywhere so the horizontal swiping works
when your fingers anywhere on the
extension and vertical swiping only
works in one place not that kind of
confuse me I thought that was
unnecessary you'll notice that some
extensions but not all have extra
screens available and notice that Romans
put really nice-looking Chevron's I'm
just kidding he put a Settings icon on
the ones that have settings so it's
really obvious how to get to the second
page if there is one and it's also
really obvious which extensions don't
have a second page so Bravo there the
second page is also an interesting study
in how to do an action bar right so he's
gone to a page of settings for an
extension which may or may not have been
written by the author of the app because
dashclock actually accepts third-party
extensions really kind of cool so he has
changed the action bar from blue to
black and then of course put a nice
little icon in the corner there to let
you know when how
can get back to your main settings page
when you actually use this widget it can
display in two different modes there's
sort of compact mode here where you see
just the clock and a minimal version of
some of the widgets or extensions that
you've chosen or the full mode where you
can see all of the information the only
thing that I thought was difficult to
use about this app actually was that
while I can customize a great deal about
the appearance
I couldn't customize it with a preview
that was on top of my wallpaper so as
you can see it was difficult for me to
get a set of appearance settings that
actually worked with the kind of busy
wallpaper that I have on my phone so
it's a little disappointed in that I was
also a little disappointed in some of
the extensions I actually don't know
which ones Roman wrote and which ones
other people wrote but as you can see in
this shot there's a couple of extensions
you know for instance the upcoming
alarms or the mail extension that are
perfect just a little icon with all of
the information you need but there's a
couple of other extensions that get cut
off and ellipse aside and that seems to
me to be a really big problem I don't
know if that area is just too small or
if it needs some somewhere design
thought or maybe Roman this needs to do
something about third-party extensions
but as soon as you see ellipses in that
area and you're really confused the only
other thing that I was a little bugged
about was the appearance dialog which I
don't have a screenshot of and the
reason I don't is because I've got a lot
of nitpicks but they're all designed
nits and they don't have really have
anything to do with the app clinic so
Rome and I are going to have
meet up in New York and I'm gonna show
him exactly what's going on and then if
I'm lucky I'll be back to the show yeah
all right so let's go ahead and move on
so some of the most important aspects of
building and good widgets are pretty
much invisible to the user yeah but
they're not invisible to the app that's
hosting your widgets so luckily we have
the developer of several app widget
hosting apps
Kevin berry of Tesla coil and he is the
developer of the app launcher Nova
Launcher yeah we interviewed him
yesterday to find out what he's learned
about good widget design so to find out
a little bit more about how you can
build really great quality widgets we've
got Kevin berry from a Tesla coil
software developer of a very popular
home screen replacement Nova Launcher
now he's been developing a nova launcher
which is a replacement for the home
screen which means he can see firsthand
what happens when you build a widget
which doesn't really work very well so
let's let's throw it over to Kevin find
out a little bit more so can you start
off by telling us a little bit about
yourself and Tesla coil software oh sure
so as readers said I'm Cavanaugh I do
Nova Launcher in which a lacquer which
both can host widgets testify software
is just me else it's a small operation
on nova launcher is built off being a
open-source Android launcher so isn't it
good a good base to work with excellent
excellent and so it's just yourself are
you able to do this full-time or is this
a hobby that you do on the weekends
again this has been my fault
like widget just would you like no
that's fantastic always good to see you
someone who's able to take care
something fun and turn it into a day job
so nicely done all right so I guess what
we're talking about today is widgets and
so can you tell us a little bit about
how you know how is it that you're able
to give us some of these these
efficiency gains or how do you get that
extra insight into what makes a good
widget also a lot of the launcher is
displaying the widgets
being fast and smooth and disclaimer the
widgets is a lot harder than you think
the widgets are generally content-rich
which it makes sense for the widget
provider and it makes sense for the user
they want to see with beautiful images
but it uses a fair amount of memory and
so this just using the memory normal
launcher can hit its memory or any logic
its memory limits for having too many of
these widgets or changing out these
images can cars cost garbage collections
just gonna slow the scroll on the
culantro
so really I like to see the languages
that are just using the way in miniature
sized ear that using these images
they're sending them efficiently so it's
less work on the launcher and it keeps
everything so alright so basically the
the better the the better the widget the
more smooth fast and efficient you
launcher can be yeah I mean users care
about this and they will start noticing
it's it's not the launch nice so that's
a yet another vested interest it's
interesting it's something we found last
year at i/o we made a big deal about you
know project butter making everything
smoother and faster and everything else
so it becomes incredibly important when
you're embedding someone else's app you
know their widget into your app you know
if you want what you're doing to be
smooth and buttery and users like you
say really do care it's important that
the things you're putting in there work
as well so what are some of the most
common best practices or I guess maybe
anti patterns either way you want to
look at it that you've you've seen
widget developers use or not use which
you'd like to share
yes so the main thing I wanted to talk
about was how it's at the images and so
there's two popular ways of sending the
images on what is to use the remote
views they have a odd set fit now per
second to give it that and this is
pretty nasty if you use it for a small
bitmap that's fine and it's convenience
you just generate your bitmap and you
send it who has to happen here is first
your service your widget service has to
like make a copy of all the pixels of
the bitmap so that's a large amount then
it gives it to the android framework
where that has to hold on to it for a
little while then it sends it to the
launcher the launch of in has to fun
parcel map so it's creating another copy
of it saying a large amount of double
the memory needed for the image and then
we can optionally display so this is its
craving garbage and Android has a
transaction size limit so you
individually can only transfer so much
and I only other which we can receive so
much and it's like if I have too many
widgets saying that bits at once
I can't handle it I'll crash um so this
you sending the next through through
parcels through binders is just it's bad
um there's a better method we're just
used to em if you set image URI on so
this means that your binder overhead is
really small you're just making your eye
and sending that over then the launcher
itself loads up um
this odd there's some tricks to using
this though it means you have to have
your eye so you need a content provider
for it and previously I've seen witches
use the file colon slash slash as the
URI and this worked but some future
version of Android is gonna have the
read external storage permission and the
default launcher doesn't have that at
this time I kind of doubt it'll get it
so you don't want to be using this file
and such especially all right stating
need to create your own kind of wrapper
your eye that can just open up the input
stream and send that send it on I don't
have a good example of that as I'm not
making the widget just for seen yet
another down the side of the second
majority's is not asynchronous um but
neither is the set the second interview
bitmap this is something I'll clean
future version the android framework can
help with is letting widgets which is
asynchronously not lagging the launcher
and you still want to use small images
here because even if you know now you're
not creating the copy of it but you're
still giving this potentially large
image to launch display and the laundry
this has to
diamonds taking time to scale up anis
using uncle mantras memory I've
seen like some contact which it's
scrollable contact which is smoking I
see a flame through me scroll but when
you fling through and it's there loading
like the full sized contact could be
like thousand pixels while a 96 by 96
scale those ahead of time save them as
backs take heart or save them to your
internal storage of something and then
just give the launcher the smallest
version you need that makes a lot of
sense I wonder if along the same lines
using something like remember exactly
the name but a drawable we were able to
set the image level so that you have
basically rather than having to send
through the the bitmap of the drawable
every time you want to change it you
could just basically send through the
the int value of the level that you want
to display would that sort of approach
work similarly yes for something like
you could use like that but for
something where you're getting dynamic
content you know it's not in your
resources makes a lot of sense so going
along the same lines you know you're
mentioning that you know if you get too
many updates from too many widgets at
the same time then that's going to cause
you problems in processing all of those
and something which we've talked about
before as well which is widgets it's
important to keep them updated but it's
also important not to refresh them too
often from your experience you have sort
of a best practice what you would
recommend as an appropriate frequency
with which to refresh your widgets um I
guess it's when it happens like
normalization tries if you're if you're
scrolling through the screen it tries to
kind of defer those which are updates
but it's tricky to do that though for
that so you can't always manage to do so
um really the only billion ryokan I've
had is when they people have animated
which is which
Android does not support animated
widgets and but then you have to do it
is it excludes the whole system to a
crawl
really don't do it absolutely and it's
one of the the key tips that we say is
you know you should really only be
updating kind of on demand and certainly
no more frequently than every sort of 30
minutes it's almost like you want to
send as much content to a widget as you
can and then have it use things like
image pages to you know modify the
content without having to sort of send
stuff to it to constantly have to
process so I wonder you know efficiency
aside are there certain things what
you're seeing a lot of people making
mistakes on things causing crashes in in
widgets which you then have to deal with
women within your launcher yes the
widgets can crash can undo crashed
launcher so normal on shirts tries to
catch these and just brush the widget
not all thing but then I say crash
report so I can try to contact which
developers I can't always so some common
things are there is a legal state
exception that can happen if you update
a ListView adapter not from the UI
thread without oh and this have an
analyst field but it happens to which
bits tip - so when you're updating the
adapter used for your scrollable widget
make sure you found the best practice is
there you're updating it from the UI
thread and you're finding changes
there's transaction to large which I
kind of touched about before which isn't
generally that sort of the next but no
matter what you're doing don't don't
embed a huge amount of information in
your widget update I'll try to get it
from a content provider if you can oddly
enough there's security exceptions
sometimes um sometimes the sometimes
wishes will ask the launcher just
displace them from a kind of provider it
doesn't have access to like getting
something from a contacts provider or
whatever I imagine these are caught
pretty quickly but some like the LG
launcher does have more permissions it
has permissions to the contact provider
so you can just test on some skin phone
you're not necessarily going to see
these so you don't have tests on the
third-party launcher as well
yeah that's a good point as well right
in that
the widgets themselves are running
within your or the launchers process
which means that the permissions which
your app needs are which a widget needs
are dependent on what the home screen
that the launcher actually has and you
can't like you don't normal instruction
sheet does it is able read from a steam
car because I'll use it for other things
um you can't account on a lunch or
having that the default Android launcher
doesn't it does now because but one
Android doesn't the Android lock the
default launcher probably one and the
different launchers native difference
this is different from the widget
crashing but the on the galaxy s3 the
default launcher at Samsung's launcher
doesn't apply any padding diligence but
Ice Cream Sandwich said that widgets get
a lot it's generally a TDP of padding so
if you test your widget in the Samsung
launcher than you test it in a
third-party launcher or you tested a
stock Android launcher you're going to
get patents different and there's no you
can't really control this and you can't
detect what I'm running on Samsung extra
pending because they might be using a
third-party lunch there um suggested
test so it looks good either with the
padding that the stock Android has or
without touch which doesn't have yeah
it's a really good point to testing as
well sorry guys you gotta go there one
more exception I wanted to point out was
when you're when you're dealing with a
list you go and you have different view
types so this is sometimes you have a
Hatter and then you have a actual item
um you have to return a count forget you
take count instead of normal and if you
don't return the correct value here
while you're scrolling through it your
app will crash in the case of which is
if you return the wrong get view type
count I've been the lunch with self is
gonna crash exception and scrap view
it's the key there
so there's fixes to probably increase
your get you type count to the correct
number right that's a good tip um that's
actually a good point you made earlier
as well about testing I think a lot of
people are going to you know just use an
emulator or whichever device they happen
to
to test their widgets not considering
the fact that not only are you going to
have different home screens from
different manufacturers but in fact
users may download things like Nova
Launcher to have their own you know
third-party launcher so I think it's a
good tip for people building widgets to
test on multiple launcher
implementations to make sure it doesn't
just work on stock Android mmm great oh
that's that's definitely really helpful
I think a lot of really good tips there
for people building widgets it would be
remiss of me not to ask what some of
your favorite widgets are one which I
like but other developers apply like the
users long there's a swagger which it
shows your app sales for the day or
whatever you say nice that's nice to
have on your homescreen keep an eye on
how your your apps are doing
absolutely Andrew the pro budget is
another nice stuff they have scrollable
widgets for like Twitter and calendar
and everything in contacts and I work
with the developers there to work out
some performance issues so they're
pretty good but now using proper sized
images excellent cool all right well
thank you very much for your time I very
much appreciate you coming on and
sharing some of your experience and
wisdom on widget creation with our
audience so thanks very much and we'll
talk to you again soon
thanks so some really useful tips there
from Kevin thank you Kevin that was
fascinating yeah thanks for thanks to
stopping by we appreciated and would
invite any of the developers whose apps
we're going to be looking at to to get
in touch and go through some of their
own feedback so our next step is to take
a closer look at today's apps and see
how close they are to being pure Android
so to do that as always we're going to
pass them through each of these
checklists until then we can you can
find our pure Android collection at bit
ly / pure Android and you can nominate
your app for consideration by adding it
to our Trello page you can find that by
searching for app clinic Trello we've
actually updated this recently to give a
little bit more insight into exactly
what we're planning to do week over
so we're gonna be reaching out to some
developers specifically to ask if we can
review their apps online and we would
encourage you to self nominate by going
there finding out what's what's
happening in the coming weeks and
throwing your app in there would also
help us out if you give us some contact
details so we can reach out and talk to
you beforehand absolutely now before we
go I got to ask you this because we
talked about how the the minimal
launcher had an app icon mm-hmm
that's in the launcher so that you can
get to its settings page Romans widget
larger does not hmm I think it should
what do you think I think it's a really
interesting question I think if you're
building if you're building a widget
we're just going to target pretty much
every Android device which can have
widgets and I think it probably makes
sense to have some sort of icon there
the challenge or opportunity with Romans
is that it's only available for devices
running Android 4.2 and now especially
that tends to be pretty new phone
purchase is more at the sort of upper
end of the techie geeky sort of
equilibrium so the sorts of people
installing and using the app may be more
likely to be able to find the advanced
features such as lock screen widgets so
I think it's it's kind of a tricky call
but yeah yeah I think you know some of
the challenges that we talked about the
fact that you know you can't even give
really simple instep by step
instructions on how to install the
widget means that well you know if
you're the one who has to explain how to
install widgets your chances of them
finding it and finding it useful are
probably pretty well yeah I always used
to hate it when somebody would install
an icon for their live wallpaper right
then yeah and the only thing that made
me think otherwise was that roman's
widget is not just a widget it's also
container for other widgets yes yes a
good point something to think about
we'd love to hear what you guys think
about a bad another question so go ahead
and give us a shout out on Google+ now
we'll be back next week don't forget to
join Roman Nick and Adam on Android
design in action next Tuesday and until
then until next week I'm reto Meier and
I meani Lewis and this has been the App
clinic goodbye